[Applaudissements]
deux contrats de sécurité privée ont été
signés avec des oligarques russes avant
et après son départ de l'elysée
le tout pour une valeur totale de 2,2
millions d'euros
aujourd'hui nous avons la preuve ferme
définitive qu'alexandre benalla quand il
était à l'elysée à négocier deux boutons
bout y compris financièrement un contrat
sécuritaire de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros avec un oligarque russe
iskander mahmoud of proche de vladimir
poutine ce n'est pas rien et en plus
soupçonné de liens avec la mafia selon
plusieurs magistrats européens
c'est une affaire considérable c'est une
affaire d' ingérence russe potentiel
digne de celle que l'on chronique aux
états unis avec l' enquête du procureur
muller ça pose plusieurs questions
une première question d'ordre financier
c'est l' enquête pour corruption qui a
été ouverte par le parquet national
financier à paris après les révélations
de mediapart sur les contrats russe
d'alexandre benalla parce qu'il y en a
en réalité plusieurs et puis ça pose une
question sommet de l'état d'une
éventuelle compromission des secrets de
la république avec un homme qui se place
sous la dépendance y compris financières
de représentant d'une puissance
étrangère et non des moindres la russie
ça veut dire que s'il n'y avait pas eu
les révélations sur les violences du 1er
mai
monsieur benalla soir est toujours
aujourd'hui à l'elysée et il serait
aujourd'hui au coeur même des secrets de
l'elysée
adjoint au chef de cabinet du chef de
l'état français sous la dépendance d'une
puissance étrangère